[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
لجنه الرسميه للبحث في اسباب سقوط مروحيه
وزير الداخليه
لازم
علاقه بلادها مع الولايات المتحده
للاستقرار الدولي
مرسومه بالعفو عن بعض الاشخاص المدنينه
داخل وخارج البلاد
ومن ملفاتنا متنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
بمشاركه دول ومنظمات متخصصه ورشه عمل
دوليه تبحث في جده الظواهر المناخيه
المتطرفه
السجون السعوديه تخرج 211 مجنده ضمن دفعه
التجنيد الثالثه
حياكم الله اعلنت شرطه الاوكرانيه مقتل 18
شخصا بينهم وزير الداخليه الاوكراني
ونائبه الاول وسكرتير الدوله في وزاره
الشؤون الداخليه جراء تحطم مروحيه قرب
روضه الاطفال في منطقه بكير فيما اوضح
الناطق باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان
المروحيه تتحطمت فوق مدينه بروفاري التي
تقع على بعد 20 كلم شمال شرق العاصمه
ويقطونها نحو 100 الف سنه
من كيف ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل حذيفه مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض يعني كنت منذ
ساعات في هذه المنطقه التي تحطمت فيها هذه
المروحيه هل تكشفت اي اسباب او اي معلومات
جديده حتى هذه اللحظه عن سبب هذه الحادثه
مساء الخير في الحقيقه بخصوص السبب تحديدا
سالت بشكل مباشر الكسيكو قائد الاداره
العسكريه لكيف وقال ان لا يمكن في هذه في
هذا التوقيت يعني الحديث عن اي تكهنات
مازال الخبراء يعملون ما زالت الادله
الجنائيه تجمع الادله في الموقع حتى يعني
غادرت قبل دقائق فقط وما زالوا يعملون في
الموقع ويجمعون الادله حتى الان لا يوجد
سبب واضح لهذه الحادثه حتى يعني جهاز
الامن والمخابرات الاخراني اعلن عن فتح
التحقيق ايضا في هذه الحادثه قال ان لديه
ثلاثه همم امور يبحث فيها اولا ان يكون
هذا الامر بفعل طبعا
نتيجه الطقس حدث هذا الحادث وايضا طبعا
هنالك مساله البروتوكول التي تمنع وجود
وزير كوزير الداخليه ونائبه ووزيره الدوله
وطبعا وزير الداخليه هو مسؤول عن الشرطه
مسؤول عن الامن الداخلي ومسؤول عن عده
اجهزه امنيه همم تتبع لوزاره الداخليه
ونائب كذلك لذلك همم يعني البرتوكول يمنع
ان يكونوا في مروحيه واحده في ظروف الحرب
في مثل هذا التوقيت لذلك يبدو ان هنالك
خرق للبروتوكول جاري الان التحقيق في هذا
الامر كذلك طبعا اليوم اعلن مجلس الوزراء
عن همم الكشف عن اسم الوزير بالانابه الذي
سيتولى المنصب اليوم خلال هذا اليوم سيتم
اتخاذ القرار حتى الان لا يوجد اسم معين
ولكنه سوف يعلنون عن الوزير عن الوزير
المكلف خلال هذا النهار طبعا قلت حتى الان
16 طبعا كان قد نشر ولي بان القتلى 18
قتيلا ولكنهم عادوا الان وحدثوا هذه
المعلومه وقالوا ان القتله 16 قتيلا بينهم
ثلاثه اطفال هنالك 30 جريحا الان همم
يتلقون الرعايه يعني شاهدنا وضع هناك
وبقايا المروحيه التي ضربت فيه داخل هذا
الرياض هو كذلك جزء منها سقط في الجزء
الخلفي بالقرب من احد المباني يعني هنالك
ضرر كبير في رياضه الاطفال كذلك يعني
شاهدنا همم يعني اسره لاحد الاطفال في
الموقع ويترقون الدعم النفسي من قبل
الاختصاصيه النفسيه لانهم كانوا في حاله
نفسيه صعبه جدا في الموقع حذيفه يعني انت
موجود في اوكرانيا منذ سنوات وربما يعني
تعلم جيدا همم طبيعه الجغرافيه للعاصمه
كيف وهمم ضواحيها المناطق المحيطه فيها
وتحدثنا عن بوفاري تحديدا هل هذه المنطقه
الجغرافيه هي منطقه صعبه او منطقه حدثت
فيها حوادث طيران وسقوط مروحيات همم سابقا
بسبب جغرافيه المكان او حتى الظروف
المناخيه
للمكان لانه يعني ربما هذا قد يساعد حتى
في همم مساله همم التحقيقات بان هذه
المنطقه ربما صعبه تقع فيها حوادث وما الى
ذلك
نعم في الحقيقه برافاري هي في ولايه كيف
وهي منطقه يعني هذه المدينه هي هي مدينه
لكنها مدينه صغيره جدا ولكنها المدينه هي
تعتبر امتداد لكيف العاصمه نفسها يعني لا
يوجد اي فرق بين تضاريس كيف المنطقه التي
انا الان فيها وبين لا يوجد فرق في الجو
في الاحوال الجويه همم حتى يعني
منذ الامس تغيرت الاحوال الجويه في كيف
الوضع همم يعني اختلف تماما كان هنالك
ثلوج الثلوج توقفت تماما وحتى على الارض
ذابت الجو صافي جدا لا يوجد ضباب لا يوجد
همم يعني كثير من الغيوم نعمل الغيوم
موجوده ولكنها في يعني في ارتفاع عالي جدا
حتى المروحيات لا تطير وتصل الى هذا
الارتفاع الجو صافي جدا همم يعني كنت قد
رسبت يعني اراء بعض الخبراء في مواقع في
القنوات الاوكرانيه في همم قنوات التلجرام
الاوكرانيه التي تحدثت عن انه قد يكون
مستبعدا قد يكون مستعدا طب لا اتحدثك خبير
ولكن فقط يعني همم يعني همم انقل ما اراه
امامي وكذلك ما قراته همم حول هذا الامر
طبعا يستبعدون ان يتكون الاحوال الجويه هي
سبب في هذا الامر لان الجو صافي جدا اليوم
حتى درجه الحراره ارتفعت الى سبعه او
ثمانيه درجات فقط 0 اشكرك جزيل الشكر
حذيفه عهد المراسل العربيه من كيف على كل
هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
نبقى في ذات الملف حيث تامه وزير الخارجيه
الروسيه الولايات المتحده بانشاء تحالف
يضم دول النيته والاتحاد الاوروبي لمواجهه
روسيا من خلال اوكرانيا
الدول الاوروبيه واستخدمه
الولايات المتحده انشئ التحالفن يضم الدول
الاوروبيه والاتحاد الاوروبي باستخدام
اوكرانيا
للسؤال الروسي
اكدت السفيره السعوديه لدى واشنطن الاميره
ريما بنت بندر خلال مؤتمر انا الولايات
المتحده
البلدين طويلات
سواء كانت العلاقه بين السعوديه والولايات
المتحده او اي دوله اخرى
ولكننا شريكان استراتيجيا واصدقاء منذ
اكثر من ثمانين عاما ووقفنا جنبا الى جنب
عند المواقف الهامه بعض هذه اللحظات
معروفه بعضها خاصه لكن هذه العلاقه عمرها
80 عاما ستبقى ل 80 عاما اخرى لان هذا ليس
فقط لمصلحه الولايات المتحده لمصلحه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اوعي تقفل بعيد قوي كما اكدت الاميره ريما
بنت بندر انا العلاقه تبين الرياض واشنطن
اساسيه لاستقرار العالم
ي لكن هذا لا ينتقص من حقيقه كوننا حليفين
استراتيجيين ونحن اصدقاء وهذه العلاقه
حاسمه وضروريه للعالم اجمع نتحدث عن منتدى
الاقتصاد العالمي احد اقوى الاقتصادات
العالميه امريكا وفي الشرق الاوسط المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من مصلحه العالم ان
نحافظ على قوت هذه العلاقه لاننا نكن
لبعضنا البعض المحبه وليس مجردا المصالح
وربما من الصعب احيانا ان يؤدي دور
السفيره لدى واشنطن لكنني اعمل بهذا
المنصب بكل فخر ليس لانني اول امراه بل
لان ارث هذه العلاقه بني على صعيدي
ويمتد لاعوم طويله
دبستين حول الاقتصاد السعودي في ذا فويس
قال وزير الماليه السعوديه محمد الجدعان
ان السعوديه كانت من الاوائل بتوقع ازمه
التضخم العالميه ما سمح حالها بالتعامل
معها بشكل مبكر وحمايه الاقتصاد واضاف
الجدعان ان المساعدات التي ستقدمها
المملكه للدول الاخرى ستكون مشروطه
باصلاحات
سعودي سعودي
[موسيقى]
كمان
في الكويت اصغر مجلس الوزراء بيانا بشان
مرسوم العفو الاميريه الصادر عن العقوبه
المقيده للحريه المحكمه او المحكوم بها
على بعض الاشخاص مؤكدا انه على ثقه بان
هذه الخطوه من شانها ان تهيا الاجواء نحو
تعاون متمر بين السلطتين التنفيذي
والتشريعيه وفق الاسس الدستوريه وازاله
العوائق التي من شانها ان تعطينا التنميه
والانجاز والعمل كفريق واحد للارتقائي بكل
ما فيه مصلحه الوطن والمواطن
من الكويت ينضم الينا المحلل السياسي سعد
بن طفله دكتور مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض واولا اريد ان اسمع
تعليقك وقراءتك
لدلاله هذا العفو الاميري في توقيته في
ظرفه السياسي الكويت اليوم
العفو هذا الحقيقه يعكس توجهات ونوايا رجل
عفو رجل تسامح نواف لاحمد الجابر الصباح
مع حفظ الالقاب امير دوله الكويت
من خلالها يصل للقوه المختلفه والسلطات
المختلفه التي يراسها جميعا وهو اننا فعلا
نريد ان ندخل عهدا جديدا نغلق فيه صفحه لم
تكن مسبوقه بتاريخ الكويت فيها سجناء
كويتيون لاجئون وكويتيون هاربون من احكام
همم قضائيه في الراي وبالتالي اعتقد بانه
الرساله واضحه سمو الامير بهذه الاشاره
الواضحه التاريخيه اعتقد بانه يريد ان
يقول ها نحن ندخل عهد جديدا هناك عاد همم
ما اخذ على الحكومه لان سمو الامير يمارس
السلطاته من خلال الوزاره
التي يشكلها سمور رئيس مجلس الوزراء وهي
انه حتى الان مسالتين لم نعرف
عنهما وهي المعيار الذي تم به هذا المرسوم
عن بعض لان ما قال الكل وانما بعد
وبالتالي المعايير يفترض ان الحكومه تبين
هذه المعايير وتبين هذه الاسماء ايضا
لاننا منذ البارحه ونحن نعيش يعني بين حيث
وبيس حول ااه يعني
التواصل الاجتماعي يعني ربما فيها ال- ال-
الصحيح وفيها همم الغير صحيحه ولكن اريد
ان اسال عن هذا العفو وهو عفو اميره في
الدرجه الاساسيه والدرجه الاولى دكتور سعد
لكن هل هو مكسب لبعض النواب في همم مجلس
الامه ام هي بادره حسينيه من الحكومه
الكويتيه
يستطيع ان يقول بان هذا مكسب لاحد ابدا هو
حقيقه عفو من سمو الامير ويشكر عليه وليس
به غريب عليه حتى ان همم الرجل الثاني في
الدوله رئيس مجلس الامه السيد احمد
السعدون غرد اليوم شاكرا سموه وسمو ولي
العهد على هذا العفو ولكنه متمنيا في
نفس ان يشمل كافه سجناء الراي وهذا يعني
ماذا هذا يعني بان العفو او هذا المرسوم
الذي ستخرجه الحكومه والوقعه سمو الامير
لم يشمل كل سجناء ولم يشمل كل المحكومين
في قضايا الراي من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى
الحكومه يفترض ان تبادر وتقول هذه
المعايير وهذه هي الاسماء وهذا هو ما
سنتقدم به من مشاريع قوانين تضمن ان لا
نعود مره اخرى الى مثل هذه القضايا بالغاء
القوانين التي لم تكن دستوريه في العهد
الماضي والتي على ضوئيها تم محاكمه وسجن
هؤلاء
موجوده
في اساس هذا العفو دكتور سعد يعني هي
محاوله لتلطيف او ترطيب او تمهيد الاجواء
اجواء العمل طبعا اتحدث هنا عن السلطتين
بين السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريحا انت
تعلم بان البرلمان همم يعني همم حل وكذلك
الحكومه الكويتيه تغيرت لاكثر من مره لكن
الانسداد السياسي بين السلطتين بقيه هو
الثابت هذا العفو الاميري هل سيكون هو
الحلقه الاخيره في هذا الانسداد السياسي
بين سلطتين التنفيذيه او والتشريعيه امس
يبقى الحال على ما هو عليه
يعني هذا السؤال بحاجه الى اكثر
من فيه بتفاصيل لكن هذه المبادره وهذا
العفو من الواضح تماما بانه اشاره ورساله
الى ما تنشده القياده السياسيه من توجهات
الى الدخول والولوج في عصر من التفاهم بين
السلطات بناءا على الماده 50 من الدستور
التي تفرض ضروره التعاون بين السلطات
التنفيذيه والتشريعيه والقضائيه الدكتور
ممكن يتوقع انه بعد الاستجوابات
اليها خلال الايام القادمه من بعض النواب
في مجلس الامه ستسحب
لا اعتقد بان ذلك سيتم لانه اعتقد العفو
لا علاقه له بهذه السجوبات يفترض انها
اجراءات برلمانيه روتينيه لكن من يتابع
الساحه يعرف بان كل هذه الاستجوابات هي
ورائها اهداف سياسيه يعني من يعايش
البرلمان والحكومه
ويتابعهم يعرف بانه ما ان يتم الاستجواب
في قاعه مجلس الامه حتى يتجاوز تتجاوز
الاجواء المستجوب والمستجوب لانه هناك
اطراف سياسيه ستدخل في لعبه وصراع من نوع
اخر وهذا للاسف الذي انهكر الكويت وانهك
الحاله والمسيره الديمقراطيه الكويتيه
واوجادنا في هذه الحاله من يعني البلبله
وعدم التعاون بين السلطه الدكتور سعد
تشكره على المشاركه معي في نشاره الرابعه
من الكويت المحل الاساسي وزير الاعلام
الكويت السابق الدكتور سعد من طفل شكرا لك
شهيده مقر القوه البحريه في البحرين
مراسيما تسليم قياده قوه الواجب البحريه
150 من قبل القوات البحريه السعوديه الى
قياده القوات البحريه البريطانيه وتعتبر
قوه الواجب المختلطه 150 واحده من اربع
قوات تعمل تحت قياده القوات البحريه
المختلطه والتي تضم 34 دوله بقياده
الولايات المتحده وهي اكبر شركه بحريه في
العالم
كما في هذا اليوم بحمد الله مراسم تسليم
قياده قوه الواجب المختلطه 150 بين القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه والقوات البحريه
الملكيه البريطانيه وذلك في القاعده
البحريه الامريكيه في مملكه البحرين بحضور
وتشريف معالي قائد القوات البحريه الفريق
الركن فهد الخيلي هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي تقوم فيها القوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه بمشاركه في تحالفات الدوليه هذه
المره الخامسه التي تولى فيها البحريه
السعوديه قياده قوه واجب سبق وان استلمت
قياده قوه الواجب 150 لفتين سابقتين
و152 لفترين سابقتين بالاض لذلك هناك فريق
مكلف من البحريه السعوديه بالمشاركه مع
التحالف الدولي لامن وحمايه وحريه الملاحه
البحريه
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الرئيس التنفيذي لصندوق الفعاليات
الاستثماريه يكشفه تفاصيل المواقع ال 35
التابعه لهم
حياكم الله من جديد اكد قاده الامارات
ودول الخليج ومصر والاردن المشاركون في
لقاء التشاورين عقد في ابو ظبي
اهميه التعاون وتعميقه عبر مزيد من العمل
المشترك والتعاون والتكامل الاقليمي واضاف
بيان صدر في ختام اللقاء انه تم استعراض
وعدد من القضايا والتطورات الاقليميه
والدوليه محل الاهتمام المشترك والتحديات
التي تشاهدها المنطقه سياسيا وامنيا
واقتصاديا كما اشروا الى اهميه الالتزام
بقواعد حسن الجوار واحترام السياده وعدم
التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه شدد القاده على
اهميه التعاون وبناء وبناء الشركات
الاقتصاديه والتنميه في مواجهه عالم يموج
بالتحولات في مختلف المجالات
كشف للعربيه الرئيس التنفيذي لصندوق
الفعاليات الاستثماريه نايف الرشيد انا ال
35 موقعا التي ينوي الصندوق تطويرها
تستهدف الفعاليات الحيه من بينها 16 مسبحا
ومضمارين لسباق السيارات
دوليه طبعا لدينا خمس ايضا صالات مغلقه
وهذه قد يكون فيها عده
فعاليات من الرياضه للترفيه للموسيقى
والفنون والي ذلك لدينا طبعا مضمارين سباق
همم سيارات لدينا مدمرين همم
سباقات خيل ولدينا ايضا من مارين همم
رمايه وطبعا كلها هذه ايضا تستهدف زي ما
قل الفعاليات الحيه همم وطبعا لدينا احنا
في في الدوله كما تعلم همم اجنده فعاليات
موسميه على كامل السنه وهي طموحه جدا
10,000 فعاليه خلال هذه السنه
في حديثه للعربيه ايضا قال فهد الرشيد
الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه الملكيه لمدينه
الرياض انا مشروع عن متر الرياض سيشهد
الافتتاح في شهر مارس العام الجاري
والنقل العام في مدينه الرياض مشروع جبار
على مستوى العالم همم طبعا تاثر بكوفيت
وتاخر شوي ولكن باذن الله نبدا افتتاح همم
من ممارسه هذا العام نبدا بالباصات ومن
ومن ثم الخطوط المختلفه همم في همم ننظر
اليوم الى توسعه الخطوط مع النمو السكان
المدينه سوف نعلن الاستراتيجيه الرياض في
عام 23
اخذتنا وقت لان استراتيجيه عميقه واا فيها
مشاريع عند همم
بعد اعلانها سنعل ايضا عن ما هي وسائل
النقل التي سوف نقدمها في مدينه الرياض
لان اقتربنا الحين من ايام التفاصيل لها
وتنتهي من موافقات عليها في اقرب وقت باذن
الله
وافق مجلس الوزراء السعوديه في جلسته يوم
امس على قرار تحويل المؤسسه العامه للحبوب
الى هيئه باسم الهيئه العامه للامن
الغذائي وذلك لتحقيق مستهدفات الفقد
وصياغه مخطط الخزنه الاستراتيجي
[موسيقى]
من الرياض الدكتور محمد العمري نائب محافظ
الهيئه العامه للامن الغذائيه للشؤون
التنفيذيه او التنظيميه الدكتور محمد
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياضه
اسال اولا عن الهدف من تحويل المؤسسه
العامه للحبوب الى هيئه للامن الغذائي
اهلا وسهلا
الحقيقه اسمح لي في البدايه اعبر عن خالص
الشكر وعظيم الامتنان لمقام خادم الحرمين
الشريفين وسمو ولي عهده الامين حفظهم الله
على قرار مجلس صدور قرار مجلس الوزراء
بتحول المؤسسه العامه للحبوب الى هيئه
الوطنيه او هيئه عامه للامن الغذائي وهذا
يعكس في الحقيقه اهتمام حكوماتنا الرشيده
رعاه الله على استقرار وتطوير منظومه
الامن الغذائي على مستوى المملكه
الحقيقه الهدف الاساسي من هذا القرار
وصدور هذا القرار هو ايجاد هيئه
اشرافيه تنظيميه متخصصه في مجال الامن
الغذائي وهذا هو الهدف الرئيسي لهذا
التحول وهذا بالتالي سيتيح لهذه الهيئه
القيام بدور التنسيق وتوحيد الجهود
وتضافرها مع الجهات المهنيه بمنظومه امن
الغذائي سواء في القطاعين الخاص او ممتاز
يعني كيف كيف ستختلف المهام الرئيسيه
اليوم بين الهيئه الجديده بين المؤسسه
العامه للحبوب سابقا دكتور
الحقيقه الهدف الاساسي من التحول لا هو
يعني مهمه اساسيه وبارزه هو متابعه ورص
همم التطورات التي تحدث في اسواق ال- همم
الاسواق الغذائيه محليا ودوليا من خلال
انشاء همم نظام همم
همم انذار مبكر شامل همم يستطيع ان يعطي
التنبؤات باوضاع الاسواق العالميه
وبالتالي يساعد في اتخاذ القرار المناسب
همم لاصحاب الصلاحيه في حاله وجود ازمات
لا سمح الله
فبالتالي هناك تقارير لحظيه وتقارير دوريه
باستمرار هذه تمكن الهيئه باذن الله في
ممارسه اعمال كبيره جدا في المرحله
القادمه
يا دكتور يعاني يعني هذه همم هذه الفتره
من ازمه امن غذائهم ان شاء الله طبعا
التطورات
السياسيه الاخيره خصوصا في ما يحدث من
اسماء روسيه اوكرانيه همم هذه الهيئه كيف
ستساهم السعوديه في همم او كيف ستساهم في
تجنيب السعوديه اي خطر لقدر الله من همم
يعني همم
من خلال همم
العمل على انشاء برنامج ونظام انذار سريع
يستطيع ان يقرا ويزودنا بمعلومات كامله عن
اوضاع الاسواق العالميه والتطورات التي
تحدث فيها هذا يساعد على بناء اتخاذ
القرارات صائبه من خلال التقارير والتزوج
بالمعلومات الوافي عن حركه الاسواق السلع
الغذائيه في العالم وحتى محليا همم
بالتنبؤ او والاخذ الاحتياطات اللازمه في
حاله
الطوارئ الى سمح الله باتخاذ القرار
المناسب الذي يضمن تحقيق الغذاء الوفير في
الوقت المناسب الدكتور همم اين هي
السعوديه اليوم من هذه الازمه ازمه الغذاء
همم العالميه او الدوليه جراء التطورات
الجنسيه الاخيره
الحقيقه المملكه بفضل الله سبحانه وتعالى
ثم تعمل قيادتنا الرشيده
كما لاحظتم في خلال اسميتي
ازمه ارجعي حتى كورونا وعزمه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه لم تتاثر اسواق
المملكه والحمد لله كانت كل القراءات
والمقاييس يدل على ان هناك وفره في الغذاء
والمكانيات المتوفره على نطاق واسع طبعا
هذا القرار الاخير وجود هيئه متخصصه في
مجال الامن الغذائي همم سيعطي ثقل كبير
للمملكه على نطاق الدولي في حيث تصبح هذه
الهيئه ممثله للمملكه في المحافل الدوليه
في المنظمات المختلفه وبالتالي همم هذا
يعزز وجود المملكه ودورها همم المحوري في
منظومه العمل الغذائي ايضا همم النظام
الانذار المبكر الذي ان شاء الله نعمل
عليه حاليا همم سيوفر لنا قراءه مستفيضه
وهمم اليه عن حركه همم الاسواق العالميه
والمحليه وبالتالي توفير الامكانيات
اللازمه
وتسهيل اتخاذ القرار اللازم لاتخاد
الاجراءات ثم نزلتم تعملون عليه نظام
الانذار المبكر دكتور لم تنتهي حتى اللحظه
بدات المؤسسه سابقه في العمل على هذا
البرنامج
والا في المراحل الاخيره اللي اطلاق هذا
البرنامج بالتوفيق لكم ان شاء الله شكرا
جزيلا لك انضم لنا من الرياض والدكتور
محمد العمري نائب محافظ الهيئه العامه
للامن الغذائي للشؤون التنظيميه
النيابه العامه السعوديه تشكيلا منظمه
مكونه من اربعه الوافدين من جنسيه اسيويه
النقود حيث كشف التحقيق عن قيامهم باقتناء
الات الكترونيه وطبيعه مخصصه لطباعه
العملات الورقيه وحيازتهم
لثمانيه الاف و700 ريال مزوره وجرى
ايقافهم واحالتهم للمحكمه المختصه وصدر
بحقهم حكم قضائي بالاداره والسجن لمده خمس
سنوات وغرامات ماليه قدرها 120,000 ريال
مع مصادره الاجهزه وابعادهم عن البلاد بعد
انتهاء مده سجنهم
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل ايضا
هيئه العقار السعوديه تعلن بدء العمل وفق
نظام الوساطه العقاريه
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت لهيئه السعوديه
للعقار بان العمل في انشطه الوساطه
والخدمات العقاريه وفق نظام الوساطه سيبدا
اليوم اوضحت الهيئه انها اتاحت للممارسين
العقاريين الحاليين تصحيح اوضاعهم خلال
سته اشهر كموله تصحيحيه مع ايتاحه الخدمات
المتعلقه باصدار التراخيص اللازمه لممارسه
نشاط الوساطه والتسويق العقاري دون مقابل
المالي طوال فتره التصحيح مشيره ان النظام
سيسهم في رفع مستوى الخدمات المقدمه وحفظ
حقوق متعاملنا في القطاع
اقامه اداره السجون السعوديه اليوم حفله
تخريجي 2011 مجنده للعمل في قطاع السجون
وذلك ضمن الدوره الثالثه التي اقامها
المعهد حيث اتقن خلال فتره التاهيل اتقلنا
خلال فتره التاهيل المهارات الميدانيه
والعلوم الامنيه التي تؤهل للعمل بكفاءه
في الميدان
الامنيات باذن الله في العمل العسكري في
جوان مختلفه وجانب ميدانيه هؤلاء
الخريجاتنا نواه لعمل ومنظومه امنيه
متكامله 9 من خلال المديريه العامه للسجون
لتمكين المراه السعوديه الى العمل في
الجانب الاداريه
والامنيه ايمانا بقيمه المراه السعوديه
العاليه
[موسيقى]
انطلقت اليوم في جده غرب السعوديه ورشه
العمل الدوليه للقدرات الاقليميه في رصد
المتغيرات المناخيه والتنبؤ بها بمشاركه
اكثر من 20 دوله وست منظمه عالميه الورشه
العالميه التي نظمها المركز السعودي
للارصاد تهدف الى مناقشه وتبادل المعرفه
حول التغير المناخي العالمي والاقليميه
من جده ينضم الينا ممثل المنظمه العالميه
للارصاد ورئيس لجنه خدمات التنبؤات
المناخيه الاقليميه الدكتور ولفرن اوكي
دكتور والفران مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض دعني اسال اولا عن ابرز
واهم التحديات المناخيه
التنبؤات ايضا بهذه التحديات وكذلك ايضا
عن ما يمكن مناقشته في رصد هذه المتغيرات
المناخيه قبل ان تحدث التي نقشتوها في جده
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافتي
الورشه في جده
المنطقه مركز
الرئيسي منه هو الدعم اصحاب القرار من
خلال تزويدهم بالمعلومات المناخيه ذات
المصداقيه
فمثلا
الاسابيعي وشهر وحتى القرن القادم فهذه
خطوه مهمه جدا همم الاجتماع
الحاصل على مبادرات عده وكذلك الدوره
الشركاء المختلفين مثلا المنظمه التي
يمثلها المنظم العالمي للارصاد الجويه
والتي هي بمثابه صوت الامم المتحده هذه
المتحدثه عن اسئله المياه والطقسي والمناخ
دكتور يعني ربما المنطقه يعني يعني يتحدث
عن
احنا في ال- في الخليج همم تعيش همم حاله
مناخيه توصف بانها حاله متطرفه سواء في
الصيف همم بشده الحراره او حتى ايضا في
الشتاء بالتقلبات المناخيه بكميات الامطار
التي تهطل وكذلك ايضا حتى ااه في حاله ال-
ال- البرد ايضا كذلك والدرجات الحراره
المنخفضه ما الذي رصدتموه فيما يتعلق
بالخليج دكتور
نا خبراء المنطقه رصد ذلك لان المركز
الوطني للارصاد الجويه هو المسؤول عن
المراقبه والارصاد في الدوله وهذا هو دور
البياناتي والشبكه التي يوفر الصوره واضحه
للتغيرات الطايره على المنطقه واما
المجتمع الدولي وما يحاول ان يضمنه هو اذا
ما حصل اي تغير في المناخ او مشكله مناخيه
طلعني
خاصه بي ال الكوكب وهذا يعني نحن بحاجه
الى تعاون الدولي فاحنا نتعاون مع ال دوله
وخبراتها ونحن نحاول ان نضمنك ان تكون
رحله المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي
انطلقت عليها لتوفير المعلومات المناخيه
الدقيقه ومكان المجتمع الدولي باكمله ان
يدعمها هذه الجهود الدكتور يعني ما هي اهم
المعلومات او البيانات التي يمكن ان
تتبادلها الدول بينها ال ال البيت
التنبؤ باي تغيرات مناخيه متطرفه او غير
متوقعه كدهلك
بشكل اساسي
المكان المسؤول عن توفير المعلومات مثلا
لارصاد المناخيه الخاصه بالمواسم القادمه
والعامه المقبل وهذه المعلومات ستكون
مفيده جدا لانه على وتر على
مراقبتيما يجري فهذا المركز سيتمكن من
الاستعداد للمستقبل
المعلومات سيكون يتبادل الارصاد والمراقبه
مع
الدول الاخرى وحتى دول الجوار لان المركز
ومركز اقليمي وهذا يعني انه يساعد على دعم
المنطقه باكملها شكرا
العالمين للارصاد ورئيس لجنه الخدمات
التنبؤات المناخيه الاقليميه الدكتور
والفران اوكي
الرابعه
مستمره طبعا
[موسيقى]
في السعوديه يعملوا مشتل الرياضه الخضراء
بحي السفارات على انتاج اكثر من مليون
ونصف مليون شجره سنويا على مساحه تزيد عن
55.000 متر مربع حيث يزود المشتل احياء
وحدائق الرياض المتنوعه ويهدف البرنامج
كذلك الى زراعه سبعه ملايين ونصف المليون
شجره في مدينه الرياض وزياده الغطاب
النباتي بنسبه
99% من مساحه المدينه
وانضم الينا من احد مشاكل البرنامج
الرياضي الخضراء مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد
الحميد عبد الواحد مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض وانت في
احد مشاكل البرنامج وربما هي التي يعني
تغدي مساحه واسعه من مدينه الرياض ما الذي
رصدته حتى هذه اللحظه ابرز المشاهدات ايضا
كذلك
كما تشاهد يعني هو ممتلئ بانواع مختلفه من
الاشجار والشجيرات المتنوعه التي تغطي هذا
المكان كما تشاهد في الصوره
من احياء مدينه الرياض
بالاضافه الى الانواع المختلفه من جاب
والشجينات
لانه الصوت اعتقد انه
مش واضح
المشتل يا نايف مليء بهذه الانواع
المختلفه من النباتات والاشجار التي يتم
زراعتها اغلب الانواع الموجوده في هذا
المكان هي اا شتلات ونباتات وشجيرات محليه
همم تناسب البيئه المحليه هنا في همم
السعوديه وفي الرياض تحديدا يتم العمل على
زراعه هذه الشتلات من خلال همم اليه معينه
يعني في هذه المنطقه كما تشاهد همم على مد
البصر هناك همم يعني اكثر من 150,000 الى
200,000 همم شجره وشجيره في هذا المكان
وهذا هذه المساحه هي المساحه واحده فقط
هناك ايضا مساحات اخرى غير همم المغطاه
والتي يتم اا يعني العمل
بتزويد مناطق واحياء الرياض همم شكل
مستمر مرحله الانتاج نايف تشمل وضع الب
دوء المراكن الصغيره والتي يتم
تغييرها مع عمر النبته حيث يتم تغييرها
حسب حجم وعمر النبته بالاضافه الى يعني
الاشجار التي يتم اا اختيارها تكون وفق
معايير محدده نتحدد حتى عن ظل الشجره وان
تكون هذه الاشجار لا تستهلك المياه كل هذه
التفاصيل همم يعني النباتات موجوده في هذا
المشتل لايف اشكرك جزيل الشكر على هذه
الصوره التي نقلتها لنا المعلومات
والتفاصيل من احد مشاكل البرنامج
العربي عبد الواحد الحميد شكرا لك
اختتم ملتقى جائزه الملك عبد العزيز
للجوده دورته السادسه في العاصمه الرياض
حيث تم تكريمه 15 منشاه سعوديه في قطاعات
مختلفه هذا وناقش جلسات الملتقى على مدى
يومين افضل الممارسات في الجوده والتميز
المؤسسي وتنميه القدرات البشريه بالاضافه
للتميز في اداره الشركات والموارد
الانسان بالادويه او بالاوديه علاقته
معايشه فهي مصدر للمياه وتجدد التربه
للزراعه والتلطف في الاجواء برطوبتها
التفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الحوادث الكونيه التي تحدث عندنا كجريان
وادي الرمه والنقوش البشريه والمتحجرات
التاريخيه تفرض نفسها على تاريخ العالم
اجمع فارضنا معمل جيولوجي ومتكشف تاريخي
وجغرافي وبشري لتغيرات المناخيه فقد مر
علينا عصر الجليد وعصر السافانا وعصر
الامطار الموسميه وعصر التصحر اللي احنا
عايشين فيه ارضنا اخذت من كل سحابه بمطره
وخيره للقريب والبعيد كالبحر يقذف للقريب
جواهرا جودا ويبعث للبعيد
سحائلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وعلاقتنا بالاوديه علاقه معفيه فهي مصدر
للمياه وتجدد تربه الارض للزراعه وتلطف
الاجواء برطوبتها وعلاقها روحانيه
فالجبريل عليه السلام نزل على النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم بوادي العقيق اتاني الليل
اتم من ربي فقال صلى بهذا الوادي المبارك
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
لجنه الرسميه للبحث في اسباب سقوط مروحيه
وزير الداخليه
مجلس الوزراء الكويتيه يصدر مرسوما بالعفو
عن بعض الاشخاص المدونين داخل وخارج
البلاد
بمشاركه دول ومنظمه متخصصه ورشه عمل دوليه
تبحث في جده الظواهر المناخيه المتطرفه
السجون السعوديه تخرج 211 مجنده ضمن دفعه
التجنيد الثالثه
شكرا لكم المتابعه نهايه الرابعكم غدا في
رعايه الله
[موسيقى]